[Musique]
fessenheim petit village de 1300
habitants au bord du rhin sa boulangerie
son étang de pêche mais si la commune
haut-rhinoise est connu dans la france
entière c'est moi pour victor schoelcher
et la mémoire de son combat contre
l'esclavagé que pour sa centrale
nucléaire la plus ancienne du parc
français
conçu pour une nouvelle vie maximum de
30 à 40 ans la centrale approchent de
l'âge de la retraite quand certains
envisagent d'en prolonger la durée
d'exploitation
une proposition inacceptable pour les
opposants à l'atome qui se mobilisent
depuis une quinzaine d'années pour faire
fermer la centrale électrique raison
invoquée l'impératif écologique et la
sécurité nombre d'incidents émaillent la
vie récente de la vieille dame
cristallisant les inquiétudes des
mouvements écologistes des deux côtés du
rhin dès 2012 et consécutivement à sa
promesse de campagne françois hollande
annonce que la centrale fermera la
centrale de fessenheim qui la plus
ancienne de notre parc
sera fermée à la fin de l'année 2016
dans des conditions qui garantiront la
sécurité des approvisionnements de cette
région
la reconversion du site et la
préservation de tous les emplois la loi
de transition énergétique est votée en
2015 elle plafonne la production du
nucléaire français
si une centrale ouvre une autre doit
fermer le p r de flamanville est
programmé pour 2018 cela aura un impact
en alsace maintenant il ya un
plafonnement de la production d'énergie
nucléaire à 63 2 gigawatts ce qui veut
dire qu en flamand vie ouvrir à
fessenheim devra fermer donc flamanville
va ouvrir ses 2018 fermeture pour 2018
mais c'est sans compter sur nicolas
sarkozy depuis potentiel candidat à la
présidentielle de 2017 qui annonce en
mai 2016 à demi-mot que s'il revenait au
pouvoir la centrale pourrait être
maintenu en activité fessenheim ses 350
millions par an de bénéfice pour nous
utilisons cet argent pour financer des
énergies renouvelables pourquoi fermer
fait sonné pour faire plaisir un
mouvement d'écologie politique qui
explose partout les ouvriers les
salariés les ingénieurs la filière
nucléaire française mérite mieux ainsi
en l'espace d'une décennie fessenheim
est devenu le symbole de l'opposition
entre pro et anti nucléaires un enjeu de
politique nationale et même
internationale reste sur le terrain des
salariés inquiets de perdre leur emploi
et des élus locaux qui s'interrogent sur
l'avenir
nous savons tous que 2018 la date butoir
ne pourra pas être respecté rien n'est
mis en place pour la compensation si
cette centrale devait fermer
effectivement en 2018 les retombées
économiques de la fermeture de la
centrale seraient désastreuses avec la
paire de 2000 emplois directs et 400
entreprises qui seraient concernés
également des entreprises locales qui
par la fermeture de cette centrale le
n'aurait plus de commandes et ne
pourrait pas retenir leur rentabilité la
fermeture de la centrale aurait aussi un
impact sur les communes aux alentours
nous touchons des taxes sur les pylônes
de ce côté l'état n'a pas prévu de
compensation les élus estime à 5000 le
nombre d'emplois indirects qui
pourraient disparaître suite à la
fermeture pour compenser des
propositions sont sur la table
création d'une zone franche dans le
secteur installation d'une centrale au
gaz au service de l'état de donner une
réponse aux édiles locaux si la
population s'inquiète sur l'emploi reste
que dans le contexte post-fukushima la
sécurité du site soulève elle aussi les
interrogations alors l'inquiétude
effectivement il y en a dans toutes les
communes alentour cette inquiétude 2 de
cette centrale on la ressent bien
évidemment les gens
nous les maires également nous sommes
bien conscients qu'il n'y a aucun risque
à prendre que s'il ya le moindre doute
s'il y a effectivement eu la moindre
crainte il faudrait pallier avec la
fermeture de cette centrale pour lever
les doutes une seule solution faire
circuler l'info entre les différentes
parties impliquées dans le dossier
michel habig préside la commission
locale d'information et de surveillance
de fessenheim la clis on suit de près
ces incidents parfois on demande même
des contre-expertises par rapport à ce
que fait l'asn dans des contre
expertises permettant de vraiment aller
au fond des choses à l'ordre du jour on
a un gros sujet c'est le gp3 c'est
l'échangeur de vapeur de la tranche 2
qui est à l'arrêt là depuis maintenant
deux mois et donc par rapport à des
problèmes de certification de qualité de
fabrication voilà donc la question est
posée à l'asn et puis également à edf
spécificité haut rhinoise la clis voit
le jour sous l'impulsion du conseil
général en 1977 en même temps que la
centrale outre l'audition des cadres
directeurs de fessenheim ddf ou de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire elle peut
organiser inspection expertise
indépendante pour assurer la
transparence y participent élus
associations environnementales syndicat
de la centrale et expert du nucléaire
des élus suisses des allemands sont
également conviés l'activité d'une
centrale nucléaire est régi offre lors
celui qui l'exploitent et l'asn qui est
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire entre les
deux il faut qu'il y ait une puissance
publique la représentativité
des habitants des forces politiques
syndicales des associations pour que
s'ils ont des questions elles puissent
être évoquées et est comment dire
travailler étudier et que réponses
soient apportées
si la centrale de fessenheim produit
toujours la majorité du courant consommé
en alsace dans le haut rhin on n'a pas
attendu l'annoncé de sa fermeture pour
promouvoir et développer des énergies
alternatives comme cette centrale
solaire à ungersheim la plus grande
d'alsace si le soleil n'est pas la
ressource naturelle à laquelle on pense
le plus quand on parle de l'alsace et il
en est une autre que l'on trouve à
profusion et peut elle aussi servir à
produire l'électricité l'eau c'est ce
que l'on fait à quelques kilomètres
seulement de fessenheim le nom de
l'ancien canal du rhône-au-rhin cette
partie entre strasbourg et mulhouse
acquise par le département dans les
années 60 sert à une expérimentation
originale
le conseil départemental vient d'y faire
installer les turbines hydrauliques
produisant l'électricité
notre vent de 20 noeuds de vent une des
turbines donc sur les cuisses 46 qui est
donc une des cinq turbines qui ont été
installés par le département sachant
qu'actuellement il y en a trois qui sans
fonction depuis 2015 et les deux
suivantes vont se mettrent en service
prochainement une seule turbine produit
l'équivalent de la consommation d'un
petit village comme celui de gaza sert
330 habitants sur une année alors ces
turbines ont été construites par
l'entreprise selon mme berger de
guebwiller qui est donc une entreprise
locale qui de par cette production et
cette invention a de son côté aussi
réussi à développer est vraiment dans
l'air du temps avec les énergies
renouvelables une idée qui pourrait bien
faire des petits et se développer un peu
partout où c'est possible en alsace et
pourquoi pas dans le reste du monde
preuve qu'en matière d'énergie
l'innovation ne s'arrête jamais